let's go now to part 2 of our study of
how the trumpian FoxNews propaganda
cycles work this next story is a story
that in a normal world on a normal
planet would not be a story but in the
story of Donald Trump's 2019 reality
this is a very real story Fox & Friends
has been caught editing out and
minimizing the booing and the chanting
of lock him up that took place during
Donald Trump's brief appearance at Game
five of the World Series over the
weekend so to remind you yesterday I
played for you a bunch of clips of Trump
showing up in Washington DC for Game
five of the World Series and the entire
place booing him as soon as he appeared
on screen chanting lock him up and Trump
visibly grimacing when he realized that
that's what taking that's what's taking
place the real world is not the echo
chamber filter bubble of his carefully
curated rallies that he's been doing we
talked about that yesterday here is Fox
and Friends yesterday with the booing
notably missing I'm going to do audio
only here because there is footage in
this video of the of copy written
content Major League Baseball is
extraordinarily aggressive so I'm just
gonna be doing audio here let's take a
very quick listen to this because the
President and First Lady were at the
game last night they got there right
around the time that it started and they
stayed a pretty long time they were
greeted with Miss mixed reaction but
they were out there
waving to everybody as you can see in
the crowd so that's what happened right
around gametime let's take it to the top
of the second ending right now and show
you some of that action
Alvarez hits a two-run home run that yes
so then they just get into highlights
from the game it was all great fun and I
love how she calls it mixed reaction
which might be true only in the most
technical sense but this was a crowd
that was very hostile to the President
of the United States they did not want
Donald Trump there that is the sort of
bigger truth that Fox and Friends can't
or won't tell their audience reminder
this is what was going on yesterday
[Music]
and then of course the chance of lock
him up breakout here's another part of
the stadium also chanting lock him up
[Applause]
so this is not in and of itself the most
important story but it's a really
important story to understand the
propaganda cycle this is the
continuation of the propaganda cycle
Trump goes to the game nobody wants him
there they boo him they chant lock him
up and from clearly notices I mean it's
obvious that he notices then people say
booing I don't know I saw the video this
morning on Fox & Friends
I didn't see any booing anyone's saying
that there was booing must be spreading
fake news what terrible people Donald
Trump is right about all the problems
with fake news out there and meanwhile
you have Fox and Friends cutting out the
booing calling it mixed reaction Trump
astana on the internet say it was
liberals who digitally added the booing
that wasn't really there and the cycle
just continues and perpetuates itself
people were joking when this happened
that this is exactly the way it would go
and it went exactly this way Fox cuts
out the booing and calls it mixed
reaction while Trump is spread
conspiracy theories that the booing was
digitally inserted by evil fake news
liberals how stupid does Fox News think
that their audience actually maybe that
maybe that's not the right question to
be asking in any case we have a problem
here
the self-perpetuating propaganda cycle I
realized that was going in a direction
that maybe is not the right direction to
go in we need to understand it but we
also need some way of fighting it and
unfortunately the symbiotic relationship
between Donald Trump's talking points
and the unflinching followers that
believe anything he says as if it were
gospel combined with Fox News and the
right-wing media that helped to foment
and expand and signal boost these lies
and disgusting depraved talking points
makes it really difficult to fight
against this stuff and this is one of
the things that is being pointed out by
people who were following Watergate when
it was going on and are following what
is going on right now that is one of the
primary differences between Nixon and
the 70s and Trump right now which is
that they both seem to have done
impeachable things they both are
tampering with witnesses they both are
doing all of the same stuff but Nixon
didn't have something like Fox News and
the right-wing media cycle and circus
which Donald Trump has to his benefit
and that may ultimately be the
difference-maker in preventing public
opinion from completely turning against
Donald Trump we will see make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david pakman I
am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a fifteen minute
audio book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli n
ki st.com /pa ke ma n